I'm very very excited for the movie to
be in imax cinemas because the audience
can really enter into a really full
blooded experience servant girl it's
what you are and that is what you will
always be for me it was a movie you
could walk into and taste the food smell
the flowers see the pictures feel the
table linen and it surprises you with
the way the human content hits you in
imax
we wanted to shoot it in a way that
really had the audience feel
Cinderella's excitement and enjoy all
that opulence burlap glamour and imax is
an amazing way to bring that experience
of Cinderella to people my fairy [ __ ]
where there's mice
going to the ball was so intense inside
those sets seeing those incredible
chandeliers with the two and a half
thousand real elite candles Cinderella
goes much deeper and hits more
powerfully emotionally than you might
imagine and people underestimate in the
imax experience how much drama and
emotion is intensified aside from its
visual suite is just how powerfully it
affects you I love that in the movies
myself I love to go to the darkened room
with the hundreds and hundreds of people
and if it touches my heart as well as my
optic nerve then I think it's fantastic
and imax does that big time
you